photo pi une ville est insolente
les animaux de toutes espèces prédateurs
comme proies vivre ensemble en paix et
en harmonie besoin jésuite jeudi votre
nouvelle voisine ouais on est bruyant
c'est comme ça on s'excuse pas le
premier l'a pas officier de la police de
s'auto pis duty truck rendre le monde
meilleur
mauvaise nouvelle en provenance de cette
ville marquée par la peur que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur les animaux
devenus sauvages et ton en danger c'est
la priorité numéro un
stationnement
je ne suis pas là pour faire la potiche
si vous échouez vous démissionnez
moi je suis venu vous poser quelques
questions pour une enquête il aurait dû
engager un vrai flic pour leur tournée
je vous arrête pourquoi parce que je te
fais que si vous êtes un témoin des
centièmes non c'est lui
identité cette plaque d'accord je
connais la tipp quand tu as besoin d'un
truc il assure que t'es pas récent
il faut qu'on travaille ensemble pour
résoudre l'anc est jeune et que 36
heures il s'agit pas de vouloir
absolument quelque chose il s'agit avant
tout d'en être capable je suis un vrai
flic ne jamais montrer qu'on te glisser
vous les lapins vous êtes tellement
émotif
3 la sto
ont peut-être évoluer mais au fond de
soi qu'on reste toujours des animaux tu
va déclencher dur
il est tenu nancy rognac le tuer ce nom
vient juste en bas on
la vie est un peu compliqué
[Musique]
on fait tous des erreurs
à peu importe quel jour tu d'hannibal
vous êtes le changement commence avec
vos opportunités acquis la voiture est
la partie en parrain du crime mr big one
c'est lui mr big plusieurs minutes
juanita
qu'est ce qu'on avait dit on ne
refroidit personnes le jour de mon
mariage je dois le faire mon bébé papa
doit le feu
[Musique]
durant plusieurs générations
notre famille a vécu en sécurité sur
cette île paisible
mais au delà du récif un danger nos
menaces
la légende parle d'ailleurs il
sillonnera l'océan à la recherche du
tome i du mao
ensemble
ils pourront nous sauver
nous l ol au hainaut
bah oui
bah oui mais tabac
demi dieu du vent et de la mer
je suis le goal des hommes en fait c'est
ma wii mais ta mort de milieu du vent et
de la mer et dole des sommes jetés
interrompu désolé recommence idole des
hommes à toi
partir en mission et qu'une gamine pas
question ça fait ma pirogue et tu vas
venir jusqu'à technique
alors ça j'ai pas vu venir l'océan est
mon ami
premièrement on va devoir traverser un
océan de malheurs
les cas camorra les yaka quoi
ils sont trop mignons
rayhana je découvre bah oui le retour
non
c'est pas vrai une fléchette dans la
fesse
[Musique]
nous allons envoyer mon des mousses
trafolle pas c'est encore bien pire que
ce que tu crois
mon nom est branches et je suis un troll
pourquoi je vis dans un bunker de survie
hautement fortifiée parce que là dehors
derrière ma porte rodin cauchemar
nommait poppy
sophie et la cheffe des trolls et ce
n'est pas sa faute si elle est
maladivement heureuse elle n'a jamais
affronté de vrais problèmes jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
à québec
on vient te prends pas qui parle en paix
revienne un père qu'ils aient tous
capturés
c'est quoi ton plan c'est vrai que le
monde est rentré à la maison
tu comptes les libérer en faisant du
scrapbooking c'est vers laval branche à
une somme imposable
[Musique]
ce dieu ster
c'est
[Musique]
tout ce qu'ils étaient
je pars
au mince alors les trolls de dreamworks
coupons court
parce que tu vas tu auras
mon village a été réduit en cendres
nous avons bonne avance sur tes ennemis
il faut partir dépêchons-nous
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que tu t'interroges
vous et roy question pourquoi seulement
trois revers en a plus de 20
ans comprend rien du tout à ce qui se
passe c'est tout simplement le début
d'une histoire
la magie de ta mère était extrêmement
puissante
[Musique]
la mère a utilisé ses dernières forces
pour te sauver
cobo et pour me de mes filles
ont fait quoi alors nous devons
retrouver l'armure elle seule assurer
une protection
ya fort longtemps je fus ensorcelé
je servirai mon destin
les plus forts de jour en jour la magie
une façon c'est trop facile tu dois tu
exerçais
espèce de cranach
la forteresse tenue suivez-moi
acceptes ton héritage couple
donne une fin heureuse à quand
l'histoire
si vous devez cligner des yeux
e
faites le maintenant
qu'ils entendaient quoi j'ai entendu
quelqu'un dire hey oh ça grouille de
poisson par ici n'importe quel poids
sont ouvertes libres justes là là là à
là bonjour papel tories ou santé par an
bonjour j'ai perdu ma femme ou les as tu
vu pour la dernière fois j'ai oublié je
cherchais quelque chose j'ai d'accord je
comprends vous avez rendez-vous jeu des
troubles de la mémoire immédiate
cette famille enfin je crois
nous tuer a lancé l'air à tout cela
regarde quoi sa sert a été enlevé on a
dû l'emmener dans ce procès même parce
que c'est un hôpital pour les postes
au
mois c'est donc
[Musique]
c'est pas si simple vous êtes coincés
ici
je cherche mes paroles comme c'est
triste je tâche pas super g il est à
l'intérieur les semaines on va avoir
besoin de ton scénar plus ridicule série
attendra
maman est là qui vont choisir de au
hasard et surtout si je dis ça pour rire
quand ils font chute comme ça que j'en
sûrement leur faire des choses comme une
espèce de géants des codes et les normes
des tentacules et ne faisait pas une
idée aussi précises mais pourquoi pas
oui
quelque part j'ai une famille
je me retrouverai jamais tout ce qu'un
bond aurait pas cru je
prend vie comme tout
désolé tout va arriver à tout le monde
et pas avoir
lui fait confiance loin confiance à
pékin toi elle a la tête dans cinq
gobelet
nages devant toi maman papa veut dire
qu'on va bientôt se séparer inventorie
comment j'ai pu croire que je vais
arriver tu vas bientôt retrouver tes
parents à l'époque tu les auras
retrouver
chez moi
ce sont les lions de mer de dangereux
prédateurs ils peuvent pourrir l'instant
potts ou si elle va sortir
vous avez aucun souci à vous faire
cette [ __ ] mais
[Musique]
vous vous demandez parfois quoi penser
aux animaux or elle me manque tellement
j'aime bien mon portable
elle me manque tellement de quoi il
parle ravi de vous rencontrer
aujourd'hui et ce qu'ils font quand vous
n'êtes pas là tu fais quoi aujourd'hui
j'ai un plan tout est détaillé les
actions
lui manque un boulon à la peluche là
max je te présente si duke et il va être
ton ton frère
chloé j'ai un gros problème je suis ton
avis et en tant qu'ami je vais être
franche avec toi je me fiche pas mal de
tes problèmes ça c'est mon appart
maintenant et mon petit
ligne où cathy a piqué une crise que tu
vas voir c'est cathy elle va flipper
grave mais c'est qu'un vase un vase duke
un vase oh mais c'est terrible
[Musique]
à nouveau quatre mois il va pas rester
longtemps et max
ailleurs alors on se promène durée qui
t'as fait ça
attendez max a disparu
[Musique]
moi je regarde par klose regarde moi non
je vais me sortir de taule
ok les gars vous avez rien d'humain ça
marche
je vais retrouver votre ami alors
comment tu te sens grand-père paralysé
six mois
tu conduis comme un cochon
je suis un héros tromper mais s'il est
trop stylé
comme des dettes soit bien sage et ona
oui
depuis que je suis toute petite je pense
qu'à danser
[Musique]
si on s'enfuit ensemble ce soir by one
qui deviendra la meilleure de toutes les
danseuses et moi le plus grand inventeur
vous êtes là grâce à votre ténacité et
votre talent
j'avais tout travailler tue sauf vous
chaque jour l'une d'entre vous sera
éliminé mikit versèrent
sa technique est parfaite
demain matin entraînement à 5 5 heures
du matin
[Musique]
y aller
alors je leur ai jamais ce rôle si tu
auras tu vas dans le coeur quelque chose
qu'elle n'aura jamais la passion
car garçon il est beau gosse
et dès que je vais devenir une étoile
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit mais les
trois temps
il faut jamais renoncer à ses rêves
c'est ma vie tout autre
je trouve que que tu es génial tu fais
quoi là euh je m'étire tu vois regarde
ça y est
au commencement les cigognes livrer des
bébés peu nous importe est que ce soit
sûrs ou impossible nous triomphions
toujours de l'adversité mois
heureusement on ne fait plus ce genre de
choses aujourd'hui les cigognes niveau
des paquets pour corner temps points
comme
en fallait une tulipe j'aime mieux tuer
tout court orpheline ça me rend triste
il reste un dernier mais a livré
de la poudre
du talc pour bébés et bien sa famille
n'a jamais reçu le bébé qu'elle avait
demandés ont failli freestyle et je te
demande comment ça vole haut je suis un
oiseau volé je dois savoir
si j'ai mouillé je fais pipi pendant
qu'on tombait
ce bébé et hadji public des loups super
les oiseaux ne voit pas le vert
j'ai construit mon avion pour retrouver
mes parents tu retrouveras ta famille
methot
il se passe quoi
j'ai jamais vu ça sur scène animaux
[Musique]
tu dois passer à la deuxième étape de
ton parcours
un jour qui disposera d'un pouvoir
incroyable
la justice est un plat qui se mange
chaud
on va prendre deux plateaux justice s'il
te plaît tu y restes tu veux de la sauce
avec à part la sauce pour intégrer sa
part la sauce à part la source si tu te
contentes de faire ce que tu es capable
de faire tu ne progressera pas et tu
resteras tels que tu es et je mets bien
comme je suis et qui ne sait même pas
qui tu es
je suis à la recherche de mon fils
ben pas embrasse ton vieux pour être
père
et qu'est ce qui nous prouve que vous
êtes son père et sera là c'est quoi on a
l'impression de se voir dans un miroir
grossissant rentrer avec moi obéit
semaine m il faut que tu re découvre ce
que c'est que d'être un panda
oui je vais le sénat vise à
mieux
voilà
qui ça le maître du mal la bête presse
le faiseur de veuves connaît d'accord je
travaillais avec au bout et
il faut que tu sauves le monde nous voit
jamais l'arrêter sauf si tu as ta propre
mais vous ne connaissez pas le kung fu
mais tu peux nous l'enseigné
[Musique]
personne n'a dit que ce serait facile je
vais faire de vous des maîtres du kung
fu
la brigade des raviolis se positionnera
ici est un bon signal
[Musique]
la brigade des nourrices
et c'est exactement la part
d'acs j'aurais dû m'en douter
c'est ça le sauveur destiné à me battre
temps vient vous faites du jackass et je
mets mon parent et waad de jackass est
donc je t'assure jackass jacques latu
jacques à tujac à ce que ton unique s
work présentent kung fu panda 3 sas et
l'armure de mettre rhino volant quoi ça
cherche un truc je vais tirer dessus
je prends et je me suis fait épique sur
dans tout groupe civilisé il y à un
paria
dès son plus jeune âge le paria a du mal
à s'intégrer
il peut parfois se sentir invisible et
souvent ils peinent à se faire des amis
mais malgré toutes ces difficultés
le paria persiste à vouloir tisser des
liens
ce passage est ce que c'est
je suis un touche aux salutations comme
on s'aime entre
nous serrions en nourrice de gagner
votre amitié salé voulait être bienvenue
à nos nouveaux amis
personne ne voit ce qui se passe sur
notre île ces cochons sont mystérieux et
bizarrement ou et c'est vraiment ça que
j'aime bien le plus joli sans pente nous
n'avons que faire de ton opinion quelle
docteur ce gars vient de se faire clouer
le bec
microsoft nous sommes allés capture
l'une des causes
que faisons nous c'est à moi de vous le
dire tu essaies nous avertir nous avons
fait la sourde oreille
on va récupérer nos deux vous fait quoi
là on est des oiseaux descendent de
dinosaures sur le papier on n'est pas
des gens
ouais tu m'as fait
pareil
qu'est ce que tu veux mon petit coq tu
seras pas repose en paix mon ami
lâchez vos doigts et suivez moi
maintenant c'est en colère
un prof de yoga tirs des boules de feu
avec ses fesses
[Musique]
cliquer dans ce que je fais
moisson rouge dans nos murs ramené de 3
nous par l'intérieur des murs dans le
sacco un peu de sérieux les gars
boni d'une horreur
depuis toujours
aliment priez pour nous suivre chez nous
mais il était loin d'imaginer c'est trop
de la balle qu'il passerait à la
casserole
bon
on va tous crever arrête tes conneries
je dois prévenir tout
tout le monde risque de monter banal
mais il a perdu toute la peau de son
visage et beurre de cacahuète alors sa
femme est morte regarde le
ensemble on peut combattre ces monstres
it font quoi vaut mieux pas que tu le
saches
society parti le 30 novembre